in this video we'll see how we can
perform certain types of inference in a
restricted Boltzmann machine and
specifically we'll look at conditional
inference we've seen a previous video
the definition of restrictive Boltzmann
machine it's an undirected graphical
model with the following energy function
and we convert that into a probability
distribution by just exponentiating the
negative energy and renormalizing so
actually computing this joint
probability is generally going to be
intractable and respectable as a machine
because of the normalization constant
which requires and an exponential sum
over the numerator so that particular
inference of the this probability is
generally going to be intractable it
will need to be approximated if we
really want to actually compute that
number however there are other types of
inferences that are actually tractable
in a restrictive Boltzmann machine and
one of the most important is conditional
inference of either X given a value for
the H vector or H the hidden layer given
the visible layer value of the visible
layer X and so what we'll see in the
following slides is how to perform that
particular inference indeed the
restricted Boltzmann machine the
conditional distribution of either H
given X or X given H is actually very
simple and easy to compute so the first
fact to know is that the full
conditional distribution over the whole
vector H the hidden layer given the
visible layer X actually factorizes so
it turns out that it can be written as
the product of each conditional
distribution of each individual hidden
unit given the full vector X so in other
words all the hidden layer units here
are conditionally independent given the
value of the visible layer X the other
interesting fact is that
these distribution here the individual
individual distribution of H J each
hidden unit HJ given X so HJ is a binary
valued random variable so it's a
Bernoulli and it's a Bernoulli which is
such that the probability of HT being
equal to one also has a very simple form
it's actually just the sigmoid of the
linear transformation of X as multiplied
by the J at the row vector of the matrix
of connections W plus the bias of the
neuron HJ so that's BJ so here we have
the more explicit formulation where I've
just written down what this Sigma it is
so we see that computing the parameter
of the Bernoulli of each Bernoulli here
in this conditional distribution so the
probability of HT being equal to 1 given
X is actually very simple it's quite
similar actually to computations we
perform frequently in the feed for
neural network it's the linear
transformation of the input vector X
paralyzed by the rows of the matrix W
plus the biases of the hidden units also
notice that the restrictive Boltzmann
machine is actually symmetric so it's an
a directed graphical model so really the
form of the distribution of X given H is
not really different from H given X
because it's an undirected graphical
model and so similarly we can then show
that each X element of the x factor are
conditionally independent given the
value of the hidden layer and similarly
it's going to be the sigmoid of a linear
transformation of my hidden layer H and
now it's going to be paralyzed by the
columns of W that is to get the
probability of XK being equal to 1 we'll
just do the sigmoid of CK the bias value
for the K input plus the product of the
hidden layer with the KF column of
matrix W
so let's now actually derive this result
and see how this is true so I'll I'll do
the derivation for the condition over H
given X all right so first of all let's
just write P of H given X so we can
write that as the joint over X and H
divided by the marginal over just X so
that's the summation over all possible
hidden layer vector which I'm calling H
prime here of the joint P of X and H
prime so this whole sum here that's just
P of X so let's let's just actually
write the what P of X and H is well
that's just the exponential of the
negative energy which is that divided by
the normalization constant or the
partition function and similarly here
and also I've just written explicitly
over what we're iterating where we're
performing the sum here so we're
iterating over all vectors that are
binary of size capital H capital H is
the number of hidden units so we notice
that first we can cancel out the
partition function at the numerator
denominator and we can also cancel out
this term here in here and that's
because it does not depend on H so it
doesn't depend here at the numerator on
H Prime and so we can actually take that
out so we could multiply here by the
exponential of C transpose X and remove
it from here and then it would cancel
out with what's at the numerator next
we'll just write down this whole term
here into an explicit sum over all
indices in the hidden layer so in this
well first up this B transpose times H
that's just the sum over J of BJ times H
J and also this we can actually write it
down as the sum
over the rows of W of X times the row of
W times the value of the jail hidden
unit so if you don't see this that
recommend you just sit down and and see
how this is equivalent to that and then
I'm just writing exactly the same thing
at the denominator I've also written
explicitly that this sum here can be
written down as a sequence of sums over
the first hidden unit till the last
hidden unit so a sequence of nested sums
over each individual hidden unit then
because the exponential of a sum is the
product of Exponential's I have that
this is equivalent to that we have the
product of the exponentiated terms that
were into the sum here and I have
exactly the same thing here then I
notice that in this product in the
denominator each factor in the product
actually depends on a single hidden unit
H J H prime J it doesn't depend this
factor here doesn't depend on the other
H other elements of H Prime and so what
this means is that if I'm summing say
over H prime capital H all of the terms
here in this product are constant with
respect to H prime H capital H except
for the last one except for H prime H so
the last term for J equals capital H so
it means that all of the other factors
in this product I can actually put them
in front of the Sun and just perform the
sum over the last hidden unit of the
corresponding factor in this whole
product here and once I compute this
well then this is a constant with
respect to all of their hidden units so
I could actually put it in front of this
whole sum and in this way I could
actually write down this nested sum here
as just a product of these
over the first 18 units times the sum
over the second unit and so on so what
I've done is that I've converted this
nested sum over all in units as just a
linear product of the as just a product
of a sum over an individual hidden in it
for each hidden unit so this sum here
was a sum of an exponential number of
terms and now here we have actually a
product over capital H number of factors
and each factor in the product is this
here it's just the sum over an
individual in the unit so now here I'm
just writing that as a product with the
product sign over J of the sum over the
jf hidden unit that's just the
definition of that symbol really and
then I can actually write down what this
sum is it's only over two terms for H
prime J equals 0 or H prime J equals 1
so if H prime J is equal to 0 then
that's 0 that's 0 so the Exponential's 0
is 1 and then if H prime J is equal to 1
then that would be the exponential of
just BJ which is here Plus this term
here because this would be 1 next I can
just write this as a single product
instead of the fraction of two products
since both products over the same
indices J then that's just a product
over J of the fraction of the
exponential of the factor that involves
H J divided by 1 plus the exponential of
BJ plus DGH
Rho of W times X and now I notice that
this is actually a probability so if H J
was equal to 1 then I get this term if
HG was equal to zero I get this term so
if I sum over this fix if I sum over
this expression for each values of that
H J can take which value H you can take
actually sum to one so that's actually a
distribution and so and this it turns
out is just then the probability it must
be the probability of HJ taking its
given value condition on X so that we've
shown we finally shown that P of H given
X so the full conditional over all the
elements in H is just the product of the
elements per element conditional
probability of the hidden units in my
hidden layer now let's actually show
that this is just a sigmoid of the
linear transformation of X so we had
before that this is equal to that that's
just the last part of our derivation on
the previous slide and now I notice that
if I multiply here by the exponential of
minus VJ minus WJ dot X here and here as
well
so essentially multiplying the whole
expression by one then this would cancel
out with that this here would cancel out
with that and then one here would be
replaced by the exponential of the
negative term and so that's exactly what
we have here we have 1 over 1 plus the
exponential of the negative the linear
transformation of X and by definition 1
over the exponential sorry 1 over 1 plus
the exponential of minus something
that's this sigmoid so that's just
really the sigmoid of the lamed
transformation of X so now we've shown
that this conditional distribution over
a single hidden unit is the sigmoid of
the linear transformation of X when it's
multiplied by the connections between
HJ and all elements and X and then we
add the bias of djf hidden unit and just
a final remark that really here I've
done a full demonstration of this
conditional distribution in an RBM in
particular the really useful property
that we get some conditional
independencies between the values of in
one layer given all the values in the
other layer but in fact we could have
used a general result known as the or
property known as the local markov
property for a Markov network and for an
undirected graphical model which simply
states that if I have in conditional if
I have a conditional sorry an undirected
graphical model and its associated
markup network over a vector of random
variable Z 1 up to set Z V and so here I
notice here it should be said I minus 1
said I plus 2 I plus 1 so here's that I
should not appear because it's here so
the local Markov property says that this
conditional distribution of one random
variable given all the others it
actually reduces to just the conditional
probability of Z I given only its
neighbors so in other words P of Z I
sorry Z I is conditionally independent
of all other elements in the Z variables
given its neighbors in the markup
network and so then we have that this
conditional distribution here can be
written as the joint here sorry the the
yes the joint over Zi and its neighbors
divided by the marginal over justice
neighbors where we've marginalizing over
Zi and because this is a
undirected graphical model which we can
write down as a product of factors like
this then we get the product overall its
factors but the factors that involve
either only the neighbors or any other
that I've variables in the full vector
are actually going to cancel out in the
numerator and denominator so in the end
this reduces as just the form which is
the product of all the factors that
involve Zi and any of the neighbors in
the neighborhood for Zi in the Markov
network divided by the normalization
constant so the same thing where we are
normalizing by summing over all
potential values of said I and and in
fact so we could have used that formula
which I sort of shown just by explaining
it you can do as an exercise try to see
how we can get from this to that for
general undirected graphical model that
we write down as a product of factors
but so that's just a general property
for the for Markov network and its
associated undirected graphical model so
we need the mark local Markov property
just shows so I'll remove some in the
local Markov property really only refers
to this and then we can exploit the fact
that we have an object undirected
graphical model that separates out as a
product of factors like that it actually
gets this slightly simplified form and
by doing this we could actually have the
right the previous result so for the
restricted Boltzmann machine these that
I variables really correspond to either
the XK or HJs or either the visible
layer variables or the hidden layer
variable and the neighbors would be the
neighbors in the mark up network so in
this case for a given X K this would be
all the hidden units H J for J equals 1
to capital H and similarly for fixed at
H J this would be all the X k's in the
visible layer for k equals 1 to
the size of the input layer that's
because as we remember the markup
network for an RBM looks something like
this where we have connections for a
given input to all hidden layers and
similarly for a given hidden layer we
have connections with all inputs in this
case the neighbor of this guy is the
whole visible layer while the neighbour
of this guy is the whole hidden layer
all right so this completes our
description of conditional inference in
a restricted Boltzmann machine it's very
efficient and it has a simple form and
we'll be able to exploit this further to
perform efficient learning a restricted
Boltzmann machine which will describe in
the next videos